nous voici dans la cour de l'école
principale du service de santé de la
marine de bordeaux où la nouvelle
promotion au médecin lieutenant des
troupes coloniales rejet quasi mérieux a
été baptisé samedi dernier
ce baptême s'est déroulé en présence de
monsieur jacques chaban delmas maire de
bordeaux du médecin général inspecteur
fait chaud bac et inspecteur des
services de santé de l'armée
représentant monsieur pierre messmer
ministre des armées et de nombreuses
personnalités militaires et civiles
élève de la promotion vite 267
fanni mais les données du médecin
lieutenant roger quatre guerriers
fondation
après